As you might have guessed,
graph partitioning is n p complete.
So your first intuition about
graphs is that you need to look for
good heuristics and try to exploit
special structure wherever possible.
Here's a first simple heuristic.
It's called graph by section and
it's based on the principle
of divide and conquer.
The idea is simple.
Suppose you want P partitions.
Start by first using an algorithm to
divide the graph into two partitions.
Then divide each half into 2.
You would repeat this process until
you obtained the desired number of
partitions.
That's nice, but not very satisfying.
After all,
how do you get two way partitions?
We'll get there but
first let's build some more intuition.
Now some graphs are special.
For instance this graph is Planar.
A Planar graph is one that can be drawn
in the plane with no edge crossings.
So for
instance here's another Planar graph.
By the way this thing is
supposed to be a tapir.
For Planar graphs there's
a really neat theorem.
If theorem is in fact due in part to
Georgia Tech's very own Dick Lipton.
Anyway, the theorem goes like this.
Given a graph with n vertices,
the theorem says that there's a way to
partition the vertices
into 3 disjoint sets, A,
B, and S, such that the following
super cool properties hold.
The first one is that S
is a separator for V.
That is, there are no edges that
directly connect A and B put
differently, the subset of vertices S
acts as A kind of wall between A and B.
In other words, if you take
the separator out of a connected graph,
you get two or more connected subgraphs.
That's the first property,
here is the second.
Each of the subsets A and B have no
more than two-thirds n vertices each.
That's really neat too.
Because if one of the partitions
has at most 2/3 n vertices,
then the other has at least 1/3.
That in turn means that the larger of
the two partitions is no more than
twice the size of the other.
If the two partitions are within a
factor of two of each other then that's
pretty balanced.
Well, sort of, maybe if you crane your
neck a lot and look at a funny angle.
Well a factor of two was good enough for
government work dag nab it.
The third property is the neatest.
It says that the size of the vertex
separator is about square root of N.
For the grid or lattice graph,
this result should make intuitive sense.
A natural separator for this grid
graph would be say, some row or
some column of vertices.
Such a row or column would
of course be root n in size.
Now the existence of a plane or
separator does not guarantee you can
minimize the edge cut efficiently.
But keeping this lattice graph
in mind an algorithm that can
find the separator should
heuristically find a decent partition.
In fact Lipton and
Tarjan in their original paper described
a polynomial time algorithm
to find such a separator.
Anyway there's a ton of cool work
related to more general separator
theorems.
Head to the instructors notes for
some pointers.